natural language has many challenges
that are unique and separated from other
data types like images and structured
data so it requires a slightly different
approach today we'll explore a
foundational piece of modeling natural
language called bag of words what does
it mean and how do we use it to process
text stay tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to look
at how to use bag of words to classify
natural language natural language is
special because it has structure
inherent in the language while at the
same time being very freeform there are
many ways you can say the same thing and
you can also say very similar words and
yet mean very different things
so in much of machine learning we aim to
turn our data into matrices or tensors
this is very natural for images since
that's already their inherent
representation structure data often
meets a similar fate with numbers in a
spreadsheet mapping very directly to
input matrix values but with natural
language we need to somehow find a way
to turn words into numbers so we can
stick them into those matrices there are
many ways that we can do this and today
we'll focus on an approach called bag of
words let's pretend for a moment that
we're learning English for the first
time ever and for some reason the first
words we have chosen to learn in our
entire vocabulary well are these ten
shown here words like data frame and
graph plot color and activation and so
we want to be able to identify given
some arbitrary text whether that a topic
is about pandas
caris or matplotlib so how might we do
that well perhaps if we looked at a
sentence like how to plot data frame bar
graph we would recognize just the words
plot data frame and graph the rest of
the sentence well it would look like a
foreign language just gibberish knowing
only those three words in the sentence
though we might still be able to get
some sense of what it's about and the
way you might capture this information
in an array or matrix would be to first
make an array that represents your
entire vocabulary so in this case we
have an array of just length 10 we'd set
all those values to 0 and turn on the
array indices that correspond to the
words in the sentence by setting them to
1 notice that this has nothing to do
with the order the words appear in the
input sentence but everything to do with
the order of the words in our vocabulary
list so now we've encoded or translated
the English sentence into an array of
numbers based on our well somewhat
limited understanding of English the
words we don't recognize we'll just
ignore notice that this has the effect
of scrambling up the order of the words
like say a bag of words of course we
should do the same for our labels this
is much simpler since there are only
three of them in our case we have some
sentences that have more than one label
attached to them at the same time
however since a sentence can talk about
multiple topics at once
so in that case we want to set all the
relevant indices to one leaving the rest
at zero just like we did for the words
from our training data now we've turned
the inputs as well as the outputs which
both used to be words into arrays of
numbers and we can let machine learning
do what it does best map one set of
numbers to another set of numbers all
the heavy lifting is done in the
pre-processing as we transformed or
encoded that text into numerical
representations bag of words is a pretty
simple approach for doing this task
though it's worth pointing out that it
might surprise you how
it works in some situations okay so how
might we build a bag of words model with
code Karras has a convenient
pre-processing library that we can use
to handle much of this for us
using the tokenizer class we can select
the size of the vocabulary we'd like to
utilize in our example we just had ten
words which is quite small but error
code let's do something bigger like 400
this will then be fit on the entire body
of the text form your training data
selecting out the most common 400 words
with the tokenization process complete
building the model becomes quite
straightforward and similar to working
with other structured data since each
row is now just an input of ones and
zeros using something as simple as a
standard fully connected deep neural
network can be quite effective if you're
planning on having multiple label
classification where more than one label
might be true for a single input as we
do here be sure that we choose a sigmoid
activation instead of the more common
softmax activation function and pair it
with binary cross-entropy loss so there
you have it the bag of words model in a
nutshell understanding how a bag of
words works and its advantages and
drawbacks can help you build your
foundation in natural language
processing as you move on to more
advanced approaches to encoding text for
more details and examples be sure to
check out the expanded blog post I've
linked below in the description thanks
for watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it please
like it and subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
for now get started on your natural
language processing journey by checking
out the tensorflow word and bedding
tutorial I've linked below in the
description
you
[Music]